this is our real thoughts for quest for
Camelot
uh this was surprisingly I get a lot of
people like still talking about the
review and I think it's a good review
but I think people just have this
fascination with this movie like they
know it's bad but it was such a strange
kinda like the same thing with Swan
Princess you know it's like yeah they
know it's bad but it's it's so it was
something I was so few that you saw back
then an anime it felt my hand draw I am
a film that wasn't Disney uh and yet was
still kind of trying to look like Disney
but be a little different and like
unlike Don Bluth Warner Bros could never
quite pull it always felt Disney light
there was something about the color
schemes and the animation I usually like
the color I like the color
no you know what whenever whenever they
were outside and there's a blue sky I
loved imposing my princess and quest for
Camelot and she even quest for Camelot I
argue look at the colors okay so I
always feel kind of drab to me a little
and sometimes the lines seem like a
little too clean I I don't know there's
something off about it I can't pinpoint
what the problem is because I'm not an
animator myself but well I think because
you know something we both really
strongly agreed on in Swan Princess is
that the opening song with the two kids
is great because it was looks only good
out of that movie and cuz it's doing its
own thing and it's plain to what Warner
Brothers does best it does slapstick and
comedy very well and then when they grow
up into diet Disney it's like oh shit ah
where and this you know it's fine
because the slapstick is not very good
um but the story honestly or tell me the
story if you took out Arthur like hey
this is Arthur and the knights of the
round table and stuff like story wise I
kind of be like looking for that time
period this would kind of be interesting
um but it's concept of the blind night I
think is yeah or even I mean yeah it's
not I'm a girl wine to be a knight was
like you know whole you know a little
bit so it's like whatever so that's a
Benton but the funny thing is unpay / it
doesn't bother me
yeah like the girl wanting
come a night and the blind night I'm
like there's something there yeah
there's a good idea this word it just
yes to any dragon is not a bad idea now
they're the piranhas comic for me if it
was done right it would this is
something about the execution of the way
it all came together I'm like huh this
could not work at all what way Mike
here's a fine thing too I was looking at
I sort of BAM out the songs in it and
the more I thought about it I was like
well then the one the the prayer is like
a world famous song now not because of
the movie clearly you know but because
Josh Groban always are people when it
did it and something it Italian and
stuff like that um the opening song is
actually pretty nice the the one the
night sing and stuff has sort of like
this nice Celtic feel to it and even
elements of I stand alone and even
though like a lot of lyrics aren't
thanking the guy sounds like a pop
singer and stuff like it kind of isn't
that bad and I like the idea of a song
sort of glorifying the fact that
sometimes it's okay to do something on
your own
you know everything is team work and
it's got to be you know and and that's
great but we've gotten such a big focus
on that once a while you know it if
someone just wants to do something on
their own that's ok sometimes and even
in the movie it comes around too he goes
too far he's like I cannot be part of
that well I just don't know why you
needed songs you can tone it in the last
minute yeah that's always my problem
particularly the Warner brother ones are
trying so hard to be Disney when I'm
just like you know you just focused on
telling your story without trying to be
deceiving up being like we do to hit a
dragon comic relief we need songs we do
Phil might have come up better the one
the biggest weak link like as much as
the comic relief doesn't do anything for
me and the songs are ok but I don't
think I needed it's the villain I call
the villain what a waste of Gary oh man
what a guy who can do yeah how many
great voices and is such a great actor
and just clearly can't sing it so we're
gonna have you taken this oh dude the
OCA's bunch that's the only thing I
remember from him in that movie was the
same be over and like out of all the
lights of
roundtable here's just this green giant
monster girl I wonder how much like that
it's a because I just looked I was like
um who invited him oh I mean yeah it's
so it's one of those things where it's
like I can't give them credit even
though like the the girl
I call her a girl I'm assuming she's
supposed to be 16 in this I thought she
was like bet because she looks like
Belle like like they all look kind of
like did they all have that vague Disney
guy so I assumed she was like Belle's
age I was like anywhere from 16 to 20
what no buzz let's not yet even like
Belle to me like looked older like you
know and there was me always she was
like it early twenties yeah that's why
she looks like oh we should figured
Belle was like 18 yeah but I think in
this one I'm assuming you know she's
like 16 or something like that um and
you know even though it's clearly
ripping off ballots I guess it was a
decent rim like okay that kind of looks
like you know the Disney style so okay
I'll like that she actually kind of
moved and talked okay and then like you
know it was I kind of felt like I was
watching some offshoot of gummi bears
like the medieval time setting the big
Disney look I felt like that if they got
that right and you know but then like
Chris uh Chris Alex character um like I
don't know there's time to eventually
carry always yeah when I say Chris Chris
ah I stopped you before you created
another common disaster yes so anyway
you know when he's going up against like
you know the little eggs chicken played
by Ving Rhames
uh it's one of those things where he
kind of looks at him shut the fuck up if
you look down straight on and like I
can't find like the lips are kind of
pointy and the eyebrows are a little
weird and it's like clearly if they were
looking to rip something off you weren't
ripping it off well um and again just
the initial design of this guy with like
you know the long yellow hair and sort
of the the game and stuff like that like
you know is fine in thought but then
when they actually draw it stink like
get the face right uh if from certain
angles and yeah you know the biggest
thing that I think everyone's always
like you know like the jump favor
remember the most is honestly kind of
like smallest complaint in the movie
that they don't explain enough I do the
big exploring thing and I'll see that's
probably the least of the problems is
her I remember a running joke I remember
back in the day though so many people
wasting so many words on forums trying
to explain it to you
oh well see the oscillator because
everyone on our own forums like this
over you you obviously watch a movie
there would be like 12 paragraphs I'm
like you obviously watched this movie
way too many time in just like know that
see that's the same thing with it though
like you know when I was talking about
the probably everyone's like you
son-of-a-bitch this is everything wrong
and nobody's go watch it now they're all
gonna hate you in like I think I'm
YouTube it's like the fifth most watched
nostalgic Rick what's always the ones
that people complain about the most they
get the most hits yeah maybe we're
coming back to complain I don't know um
but or I'll show you watch it a second
time or just really the majority don't
care and they're just there to laugh and
have fun I mean there's a very vocal
minority a weird right um but yeah so
it's but that element of the we're not
explaining how the enchanted forest
really works or even like how little of
like the ogre there is and like he's in
there first lit second it looks awful
wide it's like but what Wells even his
motivation or whatever I mean was their
motivation all that stuff honestly did
not bother me that much as much as like
it just seemed like very clumsily
recycled Disney trying to be different I
you know what it is it felt like the
entire script was constructed of scenes
cut from other Disney films like this
was Disney cutting room floor and
somebody from Warner Brothers snuck in
swept it up and it's just like let's
constructively it sees it is me yeah
like yeah everything feels like like a
lesser scene in the Disney movie that
would have been cut mm-hmm and I don't
know what yeah I say to myself there has
to be and there's been way like I'm not
saying this but we've seen way worse oh
yeah this is no one I know this would be
my top 20 but this would be in the upper
echelon zuv things that I've watched I'm
like okay this isn't the worst thing
ever
this person is but it uh and like I say
I mean I think I'm just always going to
have a soft spot for Warner Bros
animation even when they're awful uh
it's just it's just one of her his
animation I can't help it I don't think
that like a mask of the phantasm and
Iron Giant that's the one I was like I
knew there was another one that was
really really good waiting outside of
that I'm trending were there any that
we're really good you know iodine does a
great example of having a Disney ish but
it's clearly Warner Brothers and Warner
Brothers makes it their own and that's
why I like the opening of Swan Princess
cuz at first you think they're gonna do
that and then they don't
definitely not swamp princes what work
was we're back at WV not I don't think
so I could be wrong it doesn't look like
we're mates maybe that's an animation
actually train um
I'm not just talking with the animation
but like that the problem is most
animations I need a plot that we're back
I forget I'm trying to think of all the
ones in the year that were so you would
need to get are five but yeah um but
yeah I think this would be it we can't
think of them yeah um yeah but uh but
yeah and this was one of those I think
was pushed relatively hard back then in
terms of like that it was in light I
think there's like a Wendy's Happy Meal
or sofa Molina wasn't that uh yeah but
that's kind of down below at the table
serve his own entity even like the bat
wasn't he wasn't he doing it for yeah no
no most of this stuff was your Warner
Brothers or twentieth century um but
yeah that's one of those where it's like
it's Bluth is almost a separate entity I
don't necessary it is warm but I don't
necessarily count it as Warner brother
you know like Brad Bird is with Iron
Giant Oh Brad Bird has done enough
different stuff that I sort of go Gandhi
now he's doing live-action stuff he's
not like pinpointed this one thing we're
down Bluth you sort of got his crazy
early good stuff and then there's crazy
bad later stuff uh and in one of those
things where it's just sort of like this
this is a Warner Brothers you know it's
like where I can see ya Brad Bird mostly
owned
um Iron Giant but you could clearly tell
this is Warner Bros animation we're with
Don Bluth that's not workers animation
that is dumb
Bluth I'm making a film under one of
space jam fuck yeah
but again great animation is face jam
you know so I I always have like this
this fondness of that Warner Bros
animation because I love that what they
do comedy and they can make comedy look
beautiful I mean as bad as we say Space
Jam is it still the Looney Tunes looking
probably the best they've ever walked in
that movie I mean is they like say like
the animation for it yeah oh what any of
the Wonder I did not like s I think I
can count to order for Warner Brothers
um but some of them have good elements
and even with this one I'd argue like
there's ideas for good elements in there
they just never quite it's probably too
rushed would be my guess I mean this the
script clearly needs a rewrite um you
know again I think that's a whole
ripping up Disney thing I think there's
probably studio interference there like
no hit all of these notes yeah we have
to compete with Disney and that probably
just derailed anybody involved with it
like well now we're serving two masters
we wanted to tell a story but now we
have to make a Disney movie and you know
I don't know what it is I feel like with
a lot of these films like you know
especially with the Warner Brothers and
stuff um and even just kind of other
action films you would see like when
they get to the end and they get to the
big climax and stuff even Disney for the
most part at their worst had what kind
of felt like an epic climax to their
films and something I dunno how to end
their films yeah less or once and
there's something about you know and
even soar the establishment of the
characters and stuff and I'm saying to
myself why couldn't these other films do
that because I'm looking at these
climaxes only think about two always
small not interesting class think about
the only two we like mask of the
phantasm Joker laughing in front of ya
iron is appearing and uh and then iron
giant you know pulling shit up and stuff
yes - you know why I won't give away the
ending but uh it's a big epic climax I
think the closest maybe just an idea
maybe swamp princess where he's fighting
a big monster and it's the bad guy but
get took that from Sleeping Beauty um so
it's one of those things where it's like
yeah I sort of sight say no way so why
can't you know maybe because I can't
vocally say what the secret formula is
or whatever but
yeah I sort of say how can't they get to
this level of epicness and Disney can
hit it so easily most of the time well I
mean they just serve it this needs to
feel like a big story even if it's not
working it needs to feel big there's two
obvious answers to that for one thing
that's Disney's thing they've had
decades of experience doing enough
where's Kitty due to the animated order
yeah Warner Brothers
they've always been the opposite they
were vaudeville they were you know Bugs
Bunny Roadrunner slapstick um and yeah
it's a case of them not having the
experience to do it I think it's the
case of what do you think is going to
turn out better here I have a great idea
for an original idea that I want to do
and I have a lot of passion or alright
that's fine or here rip this off yeah if
you tell somebody just broke with Rauf
you know I mean I started saying myself
how could they not quite get you know
like at Anastasia was obviously I did
was Bluth trying to do but Disney ripoff
I mean I I don't even know if you went
tonight I mean everyone could kind of
see it which was kind of fine cuz we
just we wanted more a little bit more
variety reference no no no but even then
like everything felt like like it looked
like Disney and at some points it even
kind of did stuff it's like well that's
kind of big like Disney but it still
never quite got it and it's felt like it
was a ring hey correct me if I'm wrong
didn't Bluth work for Disney at one
point yeah good point
he worked a deal on point and B that's
what Bluth has done like the blue thism
I mean we complain about his movies some
of his later movies but I mean you won't
get any denial out of us that Bluth is a
genius and a master yeah top you know is
me one of the great masters of animation
you're saying why could Bluth do it
because he's done Bloo is done fucking
bull you know nope I play okay I mean OC
Kragh tavini min americantale Land
Before Time I'm like yeah you guys were
a big movie Z even even we got some
lesser products later but if you if you
know that gave him the money is like
dude Disney I could imagine he
do it in his sleep you know any no he
really kind of did too because I think a
Land Before Time was like you know it
felt like a Disney fan it was better
than the did you felt like a baby no I
felt like was Bambi it's dinosaur Bambi
yeah no but even the climax to that and
it is great and it's a great yeah when
you're done you just feel like oh man
you just saw an epic story even is about
these young little characters uh and
amber came out the same time as Oliver
and company and I'm like why is it the
not Disney film yeah was more of a
Disney film in the actual Disney film
and that's when Disney was starting to
lose its footing and get it back uh but
yeah and I always sort of wonder it's
like I just sort of got the idea like
this feel you know even if it didn't
work you could still sort catch this
feel like what they told Blair Nimoy
with a weighted Star Trek 3 they said
make it operatic make it big make it
epic and even if you don't like the film
it is that it's a big operatic yeah
there's one other thing I think we're
not we also have to remember a the dark
power of Eisner you know behind your
back but be Disney that company is a
monster I mean it's huge it's got just
it's getting literally I think Disney
has a Scrooge McDuck vault just full of
money and I think the CEO is like diving
in every evening and like so you have
this sure that is entirely yeah you have
this immense immense power behind you
and you know people like well water
buddies is huge tuna yeah they are not
like a Disney no no even let's let's
even assume that they're both the same
size Time Warner and Disney like they're
both huge companies and they both have a
ton of money and power behind them but
Warner Brothers is not throwing all
their effort into animation that's what
Disney was that's what Disney is Warner
Brothers is animation was always a
little more on the cheap a little more
vaudevillian I think when they did it
when they tried to break into film
animation I don't think their heart was
it I think that was always the thing I
think they thought they could kind of
like half ass in here will throw the
money in this way throw money let's
receive anything sticks but if you're
not just going to invest
all into it I think that was also part
of mourn above his problems the the
projects always felt and it's not for
the people that worked on it I think the
people worked on it probably through as
much as they couldn't do it but they
always felt kind of cheap like there was
no real backing behind it like they were
never quite sure this was gonna work I
don't think there's ever quite any
nowadays really because there is just so
much media everywhere you have to try
and make a um you have to take risks
with your idea and we're seeing a lot of
that happening with movies and TVs and
kid shows as well and a lot of them are
paying off and so nowadays the idea of
taking a risk or doing something
different is not that strange back then
it really was because it was such a
fearful thing to try and do especially
in the early 90s and late 80s up at
least for kids entertainment so when
Disney was down for a while sort of a
late 70s and 80s honor that's when Bluth
came in these other Animation Studios
and they were doing these are they're
actually doing ok I think that's when
Disney's like we got to get her shit
back and we got a you know ya Canton bro
and they did it yeah so it lived long
enough to see himself become the villain
in that case um but yeah so it's one of
those things where it's like when they
do it it's like it comes uh it comes
back and it works but yeah this idea of
sort Inc of respect then was not a thing
it was trying to do what everyone else
was doing and it is nice now to see me
oMG my dude only two risks that worked
was mask of the phantasm and the Iron
Giant which neither were financial heads
yeah and they both but they both felt
like risks yeah yeah and they didn't pay
off so I'm sure they were jet at the
time I mean now we regard them as
classics but you know don't mask that
okay I'm gonna say this about masks the
Phantom's of say say put it out there I
swear to God I saw ads for that movie
and one week later it was gone and I'm
like where the fuck did it go
cause I wanted to see that movie when it
came out and I never could I could only
see it on video and I don't that like I
think war number I think this is part of
what I was saying I think wonder brother
is just kind of like pulled it like I
was gonna do it I just just just pull it
like and
if you second-guess yourself I think
that's part of the problem you know the
advertising honestly they did not I do
mer seen the commercials everywhere but
they didn't make it that interests you
see Batman looking behind a corner and
like the phantasm like woohoo going away
sometimes the Joker would laugh like
that was about it you can say well you
were in high school and we were off for
Christmas break and I want to see it
sometime over Christmas break didn't get
a chance the first week of Christmas
break it's a - meows notes go ahead yeah
well in the second week of Christmas
break I just remember like nobody had it
and I'm like what the hell happened here
no you know what uh you know what - I
remember when it came out on VHS I
played I would have my friends over and
we would watch it and all of them loved
it and they said well why did this film
- well in the theater I always said did
you see it no that's why yeah what'd you
see it though that's my question I I
don't know I do can't remember being
around good to see a Batman movie around
Christmas that's one of the reasons but
no Batman Returns was centered around
Christmas and that didn't do that was a
summer movie though yeah
so that was even more confusing but yeah
I always I always felt bad and even
quest for Camelot and swamp princes all
these dead it never had the trust from
corporate behind it I always felt like
this was almost a lark for them and that
they were always nervous a little
experimenting it's always let's say
always it was always like testing the
waters and it always felt like even in
the advertisements there was this almost
sly wink like yeah the ants go check it
out be nice well did you see Disney ads
and they market it as an event yeah it's
like it's always like this big event and
I remember the ads for like quest for
Camelot and all the other films they
always just felt like yeah see this may
be got some time to be nice but it's
like you know you know if you can get
some time maybe check out Swan Princess
or you know what there's a fucking Lion
King you know that's grab an epic yeah
I mean yeah you're yeah I think you're
kind of right they never dedicated like
everything to it it feels like um but
turns out was that greater moving yeah
so I mean it doesn't that makes a huge
difference but still uh so yeah I think
yeah I think we talked about everything
about the movie except the actual movie
the more I think about um how much to
talk about kind of true
oh forget all out in the in the
beginning but yeah so there you go
that's about and I kind of sort of a
comment or it's not oh it's not the
worst thing ever but yeah I realize
there's some sort of cult following
around it but I don't get it
um yeah and the actual explanation part
is not like the biggest problem for me
it's more it's just a clumsy and stuff
there's a lot stuff that doesn't make
the lens looks great on paper didn't
execute yeah look good on paper but then
when you had to animate the paper if I
loved them together that's where I kind
of fell over uh so yeah there it is
we'll see the next one later